pas oublier que les kanak sont là jean
marie tjibaou défenseur de la cause
kanak en nouvelle calédonie un militant
qui a lutté pour l'indépendance
shay est content ou pas quand un prêtre
avant d'être militant jean marie tjibaou
s'engage pour la cause kanak non les
années 70 sur le plan culturel d'abord
en 1975 il crée le festival mélanésie à
2000 donc les enfants ça les étrangers
le combat de jean marie tjibaou est
surtout politique
c'est l'indépendance le peuple colonisé
c'est le peuple indigène
en 1984 il regroupe les partisans de
l'indépendance au sein du fln ks le
front de libération nationale kanak et
socialiste ouvert à la discussion non
plus la souveraineté pleines du pays pas
moins voilà le combat de tjibaou en 1987
l'état de son côté propose un référendum
sur l'autodétermination pas sur
l'indépendance
le fln k s appelle alors au boycott
comme indépendantiste ne sommes pas
autonomistes le conflit s'envenime en
1988 des gendarmes sont prises en otage
par le fln ks jean marie tjibaou a donné
les consignes mais ne fait pas partie du
commando voilà ce qu'il disait deux
jours plus tôt il y aura dix ans
bilan après l'assaut 19 indépendantistes
tué et deux militaires
un mois plus tard les négociations avec
l'état reprennent autour d'une table à
paris jean marie tjibaou est là le 26
juin 1988
les accords de matignon sont signés un
scrutin d'autodétermination est prévu
pour 1998
dans ce cas là venez sera reconnaître
que ces accords ont constitué un pas
important
l'autodétermination vote et non
l'indépendance
encore une fois ce n'est pas assez pour
une frange des militants le 4 mai 1989
jean marie tjibaou est la cible
d'extrémistes kanak il est assassiné
[Musique]